good morning to you Barbara good morning
Sarah Jane how are you what's going on
you sir do I do you have are you Sarah
are you Seri Jane I'm Sarah Jane but you
didn't what Bab so you can call me SJ if
I can call you Babs its J what's
happening down at Covent Garden today oh
it's great it's as usual everybody's
here we'll just getting ready to you
know so sell all these poppies and raise
money for our wonderful troops and their
families I must not the must you know
it's very important the families who you
know that you guys go off and they're
left and and and all the aggravation is
the family gets doesn't it you know so
so anyway so we're trying to raise I
mean it's going to be hard because last
year's you know was an amazing year
because it was an anniversary I mean he
had all those wonderful poppies and it
captured it really captured the
imagination of everybody and so we're
going to find it a bit hard this year
but we've decided but rather than go
around on a bus we're going to go down
in the chute in the tube what do you
think they're trying to tell me
something outside but I mean but there's
all those two people we always forget
about them you know so that's what we're
gonna do in a moment I like you sales
tactics Barbara or Bab since we're now
on that kind of terms and just in terms
of you shaking your bucket today do you
find it quite hard to sell poppies or is
it quite a willing audience no it's no
it's a winning audience it really is but
they mustn't but they mustn't forget I
Eve even the people who come from abroad
are very kind very kind you know they
really really are they put them with
their pennies in and and no it isn't
hard because it's our guys and
you know and it's been part of our lives
forever isn't it our forces and they
will always be part of our lives and and
and it's lovely and they love to see red
white and blue
you wouldn't think think it sometimes
you know with what we hear but they
please believe me when they see those
flags and all the rest of it they put
their their money in the in the little
you know slots Baptist Jackie here from
the Sports Desk it is amazing isn't it
that it seems to be so much more
high-profile now than say 10 years ago
wearing a puffy now I need I need to ask
you does it matter what kind of popper
you wear because I I lose my poppies all
the time I can lose like 3 in the space
of our show so now I've got a badge
poppy
I'm delighted because it means I've got
and I don't lose it but you can you can
come in for a bit of stick for sort of
wearing a glittery one but does it
matter well I've got a glyceride on now
but then I am then I am you know what
presently but I don't care as long as I
put a poppy
you know puppy in my my lapel on the day
and I did that's tomato you just bought
something I never thought I'd say this
but I'm really sad I don't see the poppy
sellers anymore you know I even said
look I'll go up Marilu mode where I live
and our soap operas but we used to see
them did work didn't we
something has happened I don't know if
there's been a little bit of problems
with them when you know people have
stole their money or whatever I don't
know but we need to get those poppy
people we need to get the young people
you know selling poppies and what would
you say to those who don't want to wear
a poppy well we we do have to apologize
for your language but we get we get the
sentiment we get said well it's not
really because you know Saudis dirt
isn't it you can throw dirt at them and
tell them to give away yes that's it
will you try to raise it you're trying
to raise a million pounds in just one
day today so the pressures really on you
to tell us about how you can reach out I
don't know I don't know I just
I'm terrible if I usually do it on a bus
and I'm jumping on enough off the bus so
anyways the raise money but we we will
get it I know we will get it because
we're the great nation and as I say the
people who come from abroad there was
kind that they really do people it's
that forces think about it what would we
do without them looking after us well
Barbara with me today you're going to be
well on target so good luck with all
your fundraising today out there with
your glittery coffee Barbara Windsor
thank you so much and yeah and thank for
your time thank you very much you're
welcome you're welcome
I hope your oyster cards topped up